what is the real sentiment that goes on
inside a locker room where you have
biological females and then suddenly you
have a biological male
that enters that locker room and is
changing is i don't know i guess you
guys take showers in there i don't know
what it looks like but just walk me
through what that experience is like i
actually cannot imagine
so especially in a sport like swimming
where you do have to undress you put
your suit on um after warm-up you go
into the locker room to put a different
suit on which takes about 15 minutes so
you're you know fully exposed these
suits are skin tight
so it's kind of an ordeal putting them
on
but you know you're led to believe that
a locker room is a place you can be
vulnerable with your teammates with
other people who share the same anatomy
but when you're standing in there one
when you're not forewarned that you will
be sharing that space with the male
because we had no idea what that was
going to look like
and you're completely naked and a
six-four male walks in who still has all
male parts and actually still likes
females still is sexually attracted to
females
how is this not sexual harassment of
some form
it's absolutely insane it's
uncomfortable it's a violation of our
privacy and of our rights as females to
have that safe space where you can
undress you know without having to feel
like male eyes are on you
was in the locker room was was leah kind
of like off on her own or were they were
she integrated into i'm just trying to
visualize is it a bunch of biological
females kind of off to one side and then
leah over here did it look more
integrated what what did it look like if
if i were to just walk in and look
around would i have noticed that there
was tension in the air or there was
feelings of discomfort in the air
i you definitely would have noticed
because you know these are girls who you
know you're competing with teams all
over the nation you have friends all
over the nation you're so excited to see
each other the locker room is a place
normally of chatter and just people you
know getting to rekindle friendships
it's an awesome experience especially at
that level um but when a sixth floor
male walks in it's silent
which is not the norm it's nothing like
i've ever seen before
so to answer your question would you
have noticed
first of all you would have noticed
based off sheer height and obviously any
sort of anatomy
is going on
um but yes it was um definitely a
different experience than i've ever been
a part of and i've been in locker rooms
you know the past 15 years
so
i'm curious if you know anything about
whether parents at this point were
making any complaints because i imagine
there were a lot of parents who had
daughters who were on this team or you
know are maybe even involved in other
sports and kind of looking at the trend
and feeling uncomfortable with this do
you know if there were any complaints
made from parents at that time or
conversations that were had behind the
scenes between parents and
administrators
for sure
i know my parents
were not happy about it my dad this is
something that he wanted to to handle
himself and like dad
but you know it's
dads are not okay with their daughters
being in that situation moms aren't
either but from a dad's perspective
the past this five years ago this would
have never happened and had it have
happened it would be this person's
locked up in jail but now
we're turning away from that and instead
of that being sexual harassment it's
sexual harassment under biden's
new title ix to refer to thomas as the
wrong pronouns
to refer to any transgender as the wrong
pronouns and so we're expected to
believe we're
prompted to believe that you know
that is okay and actually this is
something they're praising they're
encouraging this
so it's insane yeah you know you said
five years ago
this wouldn't have happened this way i
think that's true and i would just
invite people in the audience who are
watching now just imagine what's going
to be the case five years from now right
we always talk about the slippery slope
on this show it's getting awfully
slippery as i say what does that look
like if this is what the present looks
like tell me what five years from now
looks like if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]